baguette devo andare a un parrucchiere
bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono vari j
oggi sabato e quindi arrivano lorio sta
diventando alla tragedia questa cosa
facciamo che una parte di blog lo faccio
con i capelli messi un po meglio
decisamente meglio allora ragazzi la
prima cosa di oggi che durante la
settimana siamo andati a registrare una
challenge con email se con vegas per per
inaugurare il suo milione di iscritti
tanti auguri giuseppe per i milioni di
iscritti tra parentesi però a parte
questo mentre eravamo li diciamo che
questa challenge dovevamo farla vestiti
da lottatori di sumo
mentre stavamo facendo sta challenge io
dopo dovevo andare a farmi una doccia
perché diciamo che ho sudato tanto le
dolci erano tipo staccate dal posto in
cui eravamo quindi mi sono dovuto fare a
piedi nudi per la gioia dei feticisti
tutto un pezzo di strada sull'asfalto e
le pietre e stato orribile
vi lascio al video perché ovviamente ho
documentato dovuto documentare questa
cosa
qualche ragazza mi ha appena finito di
fare questa challenge con giuseppe
niente io alla fine devo andare a farmi
la doccia perché non ha idea di quanto
sia apprezzato così ci sono pensato la
fa schifo problema è che devo camminare
fino alle docce e api a piedi nudi e
sarà bellissimo quindi seguitemi che sta
vendendo era incredibile foggia vale
qualche non c'è l'asfalto pensa 21 aia
ahia ahia e giustissimo la scotta pure
dove sono le donne destra
beh lì non c'è ancora la cosa più brutta
che io abbia mai fatto destra destra
destra per questa regola
[Musica]
in fondo ma mi avete preso per il culo
allora dei vetri per terra perché le
fabbricazioni di casa dentro anche lui
nome particolare il signore no va bene
ci crede non potevo fare il giro la via
non avete fatto per noi non c'è il giro
se non avete fatto fare giro ahia ahia
prendeva in braccio ct ho offeso poco la
viene a salvarlo
una donna fa malissimo ahia ahia a
queste labbra enorme si integra un
organo se qualcuno punto centrale gal
afferrare costume mi stava bene cioè ho
preso giusto quindi 200 chili che nella
mia vita non ci avrò mai però andando
avanti ragazzi insomma perché smettano
prima ci sono lavori di sabato mattina
gesù
siccome tipo dal vecchio me come i
capelli non c'era casi non faccio
tornare lui perché se non si può forse
quando avanti istologico perché ho fatto
questa cosa direi che possiamo
proseguire comunque con i nostri
discorsi non vi fu accusata sui capelli
guardate ma è esplosa la mania dei
widget spinner che non ho neanche capito
il perché però esplosa ma mi hai tradito
che se corrispondono ste mode a caso è
atteso da maria de filippi nave che
praticamente sono questi sono dei cosi
festa che è stato altro
sapevo che sono state delle trottole non
so come spiegarlo a sarov sa che tu
prendi in mano e fanno questa cosa
tuttavia non si vede perché la mia
videocamera non lo riprende melo sta
girando molto più veloce che cosa e io
per settimane ho cercato di capire che
cosa piacesse dell'ufficio spin e ho
visto che c'è un sacco di gente che ci
fa dei trucchi sono un grande esperto di
trucchi di cose che che si riescano a
fare quindi fidget finnair però questi
trucchi in realtà sono trucchi da matti
per gente che non lo sa usare
in realtà io ne sono di migliori oggi
come l'ha portato mio amico che che
insieme a lui faremo un sacco di trick
teatri clima in confronto era uno schifo
quindi preparatevi 3 2 1
[Musica]
ma passando oltre a questo argomento mi
avete allora per questo questo dovevo
farvelo vedere perché non è possibile
che esista una roba del genere
preparatevi è finita sulle tendenze
stanno ora ti parlerò della più grande
storia d'amore mai esistita
[Musica]
anche button quello visto che papa la
nutella spiega ma perché c'è la bocca
costantemente spalancata poi abbiamo
[Musica]
ma cos'è mangiato
cosa sto vedendo regalo cos'è sta roba
[Musica]
minchia non avete idea di quanto è figo
bruciare il nutella fighissima da notte
la soddisfazione
l'amore è guardare la propria dolce metà
come fa vj guarda la sua nutella
e leopardi può accompagnare solo ragazzi
io direi che consta roma possiamo
concludere qua perché se se dovevamo
sconvolgermi la giornata già ci sono
riusciti però c'è alcuna cosa però non
so ragazzi se voi lo sapete ma io avevo
previsto gli shokky bandz fidget spinner
dai tempi del video di gabry ponte
perché se guardate bene il video appena
arriva la mia immagine
[Musica]
a
3 2 1 che madonna è distinta senti io
chiudo così perché fanno gli iscritti
devono essere violento e youtube più per
restringere la violenza io faccio così
picchiandola baccarin stringimi il video
youtube costringi tiro dai dai dai
perché non di ricambio grazie
[Musica]